for 25 years cities have been the
engines of your progress in sid meier's
civilization civilization 6 brings an
innovative new way of managing cities by
allowing you to build out from your home
thailand across the world map each city
will still consists of one home tile but
there are now districts surrounding the
city districts are specialized for
different tasks such as research growth
culture or production there are many
different kinds of districts in
civilization 6 some sibs will have
unique districts only they can construct
each district contains buildings that
support its role the campus is used to
boost the science of a city after
researching writing as a technology
you'll be able to construct a campus in
your cities the library is the first
building built on the campus later
during the medieval era you'll research
education and be able to construct a
university finally during the modern era
you'll be able to build their research
lab once you've discovered chemistry
each time you build a building on the
campus it will increase the amount of
science that city is producing
the location of a district is important
districts can be built in a valid tile
outside the city a district can be given
a bonus by placing it next to certain
features our campus for example gets a
bonus when it is built near a mountain
or rain forest other districts will have
their own adjacency bonuses wonders to
require their own tile for placement and
may have requirements for where they can
be placed the pyramids for example must
be constructed on a flood plain or
desert Theater districts benefit from
being built adjacent to a wonder the
Great Library can only be built adjacent
to a campus spread your cities across
the land as you master districts a major
new addition in sid meier's civilization
6
you